[Musique]
ces particules électriques dotés de six
mètres carrés de cellules solaires de 21
kg de lithium ion de batteries au
lithium-ion serviront peut rouler même
lorsque le temps le soleil n'est pas au
rendez vous on a à peu près 3 3 heures à
4 heures d'autonomie sur batterie et
sinon lorsque le soleil est au rendez
vous on peut rouler uniquement grâce à
l'énergie solaire à 55 km heure avec un
pilote donc le 81 kg et le véhicule en
lui même fait 188 kg ce que recherche a
démontré avant tout c'est comment se
déplacer donc la mobilité verte en
minimisant l'énergie pour ses
déplacements
on a choisi de venir dans le département
des yvelines sur sur une invitation qui
nous a été faite par parme au vo et para
bd comme qui est l'institut dédié à la
nouvelle mobilité aux véhicules
décarbonés et communiquent en anglais
déconne qui va se construire sur le site
même du circuit de versailles satory qui
d'ici trois ans devrait accueillir plus
de 300 chercheurs travaillant sur la
nouvelle mobilité et le
le département des yvelines est un
département qui s'investit beaucoup dans
cette nouvelle mobilité
on commence nos tests sur une piste qui
est une piste plutôt remarquable
puisqu'elle a un revêtement qui est
proche de celui de la sueur highway que
l'on empruntera sur 3000 km entre darwin
à adelaïde en australie
un des aspects qui a séduit movéo et et
vd comme c'est que l'on développe des
technologies par exemple la partie
communicante du véhicule comporte des
technologies qui sont largement la
hauteur de ce que l'on peut trouver sur
les véhicules qui sont aujourd'hui
présentées sur le marché entre autres
par rapport à la gestion de
l'information et à l'optimisation de
l'énergie à bord du véhicule électrique